[musique]
les voitures ordinaires sont généralement européennes
agriculteurs parfois quand la voiture seule
traverse les frontières vient ici nous à moi
nous sommes du fumier de bois de chauffage et de foin
nous comprenons que le fermier a donné sa voiture
la force est armée et c'est tout
en direct du terrain
Elle est juste venue du terrain pour aider
notre armée
[musique]
pour rien et quand tu vois des voitures
vivant et qu'ils servent pendant des mois et donnent
Dieu, pendant des années, ça réchauffe vraiment l'âme
cela nous inspire aussi car malgré
accumulés en ce que tous sont différents
de pressions émotionnelles psychologiques Vous quand
vous voyez la gratitude des militaires vous voyez
le soutien des gens et vous voyez ce qui est pour quoi
vous avez investi, il continue de servir
économiser de l'aide et détruire notre
l'ennemi
[musique]